on en parle beaucoup on la redoute et on
l'anticipent paris et l'île de france se
mobilise contre le risque de crue de la
seine
l'exemple de prague récemment inondée a
servi de modèle
un nouveau système de secours et d'
alerte a été présentée isabelle quintard
philippe lui dit et si l'histoire bégaie
si le zouave du pont de l'alma buvette à
nouveau la tasse comme en 1909 et
l'époque une crue exceptionnelle
inondent les rues de paris
les barques du bois de boulogne sont
même réquisitionné statistiquement le
phénomène a lieu tous les cent ans
alors musée hôpitaux services publics
sont en état d' alerte depuis 96 la ratp
avec ses parfums et sesat de mortier
attend de pied ferme la crue et elle
n'est pas la seule s'agit par exemple de
prendre des précautions pour mettre à
l'abri la chaudière d'une maison de
retraite pour qu'il n'y ait pas déplacé
cette maison de retraite conviendrait à
l'inondation
c'est de multiples initiatives de ce
genre qui feront que la crue sera moins
catastrophique si la scène sortait de
son lit
outre les nombreux monuments un demi
million de foyers seraient privés
d'électricité et de téléphone
paris et la région ile de france
s'organise sur les bords de l'yerres un
affluent de la seine un message d'alerté
prévient automatiquement les riverains
en cas de montée des eaux
moi je pense que c'est pas du luxe je
lisais pas l'heur d'être prévenus à
l'avancé pour sortir ce qui craint dans
le garage encore nous ça va on est jeune
mais enfants peuvent m'aider mais
d'aller
la maison au centaure il ya les
personnes âgées anticiper les risques
il le faudra bien car en cas de crue
exceptionnelle l'estimation des dégâts
déjà été fait cela coûterait 10
milliards d'euros